هو لا شك الفترات التاريخيه التي اتى محمد
بن سعود فيها الامير محمد بن سعود هناك
ايضا الحقيقه نجد هناك مصادر يعني لم تصل
لنا الحقيقه لكن ربما بالتتبع التاريخي
ندرك اهميه ايضا هذا الرجل وهذا الرجل
ايضا كانت هناك ايضا بعض الاشياء
الاشكاليات وايضا بعض الحروب الدائره في
هذه المنطقه ومحمد بن سعود هو كان البارز
في بها وعندما توفي يعني امير الدرعيه
عندما انتقالهم ايضا الى العيينه ومحاوله
ايضا كانت التخلص من في في العيينه لكن هو
انتقل بالتالي انتقل الى الدرعيه وجمعها
في مكان واحد كانت متفرقه يحكمها اخر اناس
وايضا الفرع الاخر يحكم الغصيبه اخر
فاستطاع محمد يعتبر محمد بن سعود اول من
وحد اجزاء الدرعيه هذا المشروع لوحدوي
الاول
ولهذا هذا المشروع ترتب عليه ايضا اتصال
وتواصل ايضا وايضا لم هذه القرى المتفرقه
في الدرعيه اتبع ذلك ايضا محاوله محمد بن
سعود ايضا ايضا بالتواصل مع القوه المحيطه
فيها في هذه المنطقه وكانت من اهم التواصل
هنا في مدينه الرياض لكن كانت هناك خلافات
ايضا سياسيه بين الرياض وبين الدرعيه تمكن
ايضا حكام بعض حكام الرياض من الاعتداء او
قتل بعض حكام الدرعيه لذلك الوقت نحن حاكم
الرياض هو الحاكم الشعير دهان بن دواس قبل
الادهام بن دواس كان هناك الحاكمه بن زرعه
وهو امير الرياض وعليه هذا كان قام بقتل
ايضا امير الدرعيه زيد بن وطبان قتل في
تقريبا عام 1106 قبل الامام محمد بن سعود
ب 32 سنه ولهذا عندما تولد هام الحكم في
منفوحه وعند طرده من منفوحه واتجاهه الى
الرياض راى محمد بن سعود كتب دهان بن دواس
محمد بن سعود ان اهل الرياض قاموا ضدي
فاريد ايضا هذه القوه منك ان تقوم به ايضا
بدعمي فتولى الحقيقه محمد مسعود فارس جيش
الى بقياده اخيه مشاري فاحكم السيطره على
الرياض وجعل دهان ابن دواس اميرا على
الرياض بسبب بسبب نصره محمد بن سعود
للدهان بن دواس تمكن من حكم الرياض من
الحكم لان محمد بن سعود ادرك هناك خلافا
سياسيا قبله في حكام الرياض لان الحكام
الرياض اعتدوا ايضا على الدعيه بالتالي
كان دائما دواس ايضا في منفوحه فتمكن